Whoa!
Hey there Henderson family, I'm your RAV4 genie.
Your wish is my command.
Wish the old spare tire was gone.
Really, out of everything in the...
Okay.
Oh no.
I wish animals could talk.
Much better.
I wish the old spare tire was gone.
Oh, I wish I could eat as much chocolate as I want.
Well, your chocolate levels are dangerously low.
Now Gladys is gonna start you on a chocolate IV and here's some free samples.
I wish I was a princess.
I want you to avenge my father's death.
Yeah!
I'm right here.
I wish I was an astronaut.
I wish...
May I please have a turn?
I said infinite wishes.
I heard witches.
Can I at least have my first wish?
Now with Sirius XM...
Is the dog really necessary?
Yup.
Knees up.
The all new RAV4.
Toyota.
Let's go places.